so mad bum gets the baseball this
afternoon he's your diamondback starting
pitcher yeah i think what he has to do
again to be effective like he was with
the astros stay away in the strike zone
he's going to come in right here
gonna miss a fastball at 91 upstairs and
mad bum gets the strikeout
swing and a miss
two strikeouts and a one two three first
good start for mad bum d-backs coming up
on may the 19th after eight starts
charlie was two and two since then in 22
starts he's 11 and four so i'd say he
turned things around pretty well
nobody on or out bottom of the first
inning for charlie morton
back foot breaking ball wow
emergency hack and rojas gritting his
teeth he's out number one
little check swing excuse me roller back
handed by dansby swanson he can't pick
it up he's got no play
and that worked out for pave and smith
at infield single van meter rbi chance
for him but with two outs knock on wood
he's really controlled that and he just
did there with a strike out of van meter
booking strikeouts for charlie morton
his days off to a good start dansby
swanson waits on deck
sharply hit and that breaks up
the nine inning
no hit bid for madison bumgarner a
two-out clean single and there's a start
for the braves
3-2
is up and away good at that for swanson
that'll bring up heredia so a two-out
rally for atlanta darno singled swanson
walks and now guillermo's coming up
playing into this he got the curveball
and madboom gets his four strikeouts
still no score d-max and the breeze
hill tomorrow vargas is the next stop
for arizona a diving play
grabbed by ozzy albees
in the shift
leaping with his superman cape flapping
in the breeze behind him a diving grab
for out number one yeah we've just
become accustomed to watching him make
great plays
the pitch swing and a miss and charlie
morton has his third strikeout off we go
to the third inning morton leads off no
score in game four freeman's aboard with
two men out
not going this time and ozzie hits a
high fly ball deep left at the track at
the wall
it's out of reach of peralta freeman
around third he's going to come home and
score
atlanta takes a one-nothing lead as
ozzie obese hits a double off the wall
and left
that triangle cost him a homer but he
does pick up the game's first rbi so now
the question is will the
review
benefit the diamondbacks from the looks
of that angle peralta never got to that
ball
it was beyond the reach of his glove
even with the deflection yeah i would i
get to me i think the issue bigger issue
is if he did touch it it becomes a
ground rule double right and then
freddie go back
i don't think he was going to catch the
ball so it's fan interference ozzie's
going to be at second
and my guess is he's going to walk over
to tori levolo and say that they would
not have been able to get freddie
freeman at the plate so it looks like
the run's going to count so atlanta
strikes first in the third inning one
nothing now let's see what riley can do
swaying and a drive peralta's not
getting that one three nothing in case
you wondered national league voters mvp
is spelled r-i-l-e-y
once ronald had his injury you knew he
wasn't coming back we knew
as charlie throw another great breaking
ball right there
a little bit up and down to say the
least his fastball right down power
river there for strike three charlie
morton has struck out three straight
hitters he has five in total the punch
out of pavon smith is 200th
and charlie morton has 201 he just
struck out the side shut down inning
he's dealing braves off to a great start
in the finale in phoenix
that one a beauty bottom dropped out of
it seven strikeouts for morton out
number two in the fourth inning ozzy
albee's with the
fan interfered double
in the third inning these have four hits
as we told you earlier all of them have
come with two outs
and there's another one ozzy obi's got
on top of that baby he's got two hits so
far atlanta there goes albie's they got
him dead to rights
and he runs into and out with their
hottest hitter at the plate that'll end
the inning so it'll stay three nothing
as we head to the home half of the fifth
mccarthy got a curve and he stayed on it
and he drops it over ahead of riley the
third baseman he's headed for second
jake mccarthy with that speed he hustles
into second base
that's what jake mccarthy can do a
little blue pit he turns into a double
boy he made that look easy on that
double and now varshall bats for med
bomb
[Music]
marshall
just beyond the reach of all these
mccarthy coming around third solaire's
got a throw
it's offline diamondbacks on the board
the rbi for dalton varsion
we've got three of the top five
rbi men in the league
on the ground
deep short long throw and an infield hit
for duvall
so darno the hitter he was the first
brave to get a hit against madison
bumgarner this
year darno tries to split the gap and
he's going to
long run varsho juval on his way to
third and he is going to be stopped
there darno with another extra base hit
in his return from the injured list and
the braves a chance to add on here
second and third one out this is a
perfect opportunity for danger to do
in the sixth what he did in the fourth
he flied out to right high target
he put it there and dansby drives it
deep left center field
marshall back onto the warning track
makes the catch
both runners will tag terrific at bat
for swanson he missed a homer by about
five feet but he does his job he gets
that run back it's a 4-1 score another
good day for ozzy obese
and this one is shot into center field a
base hit a three-hit game for albies
seven hits in the series
sean poppin couple of strikeouts they
strand albies we stretch it's 4-1
atlanta then josh van meter who has
struck out twice will lead it off
there's a base hit for josh van meter
it's in right center josh hustling for a
second going to put the brakes on and
head back to first it's the lead all
single to start the seventh
and vargas hits another ball for a base
hit and mater stops at second good start
to the seventh
and the tying run comes out to the plate
with nobody out and webb has been
outstanding 30 games this year 287 era
big chance right here for carson kelly
to try to knock in a run
carson kelly
way back that's gone and we're tied
just enough
right to the fan with a glove and it's
four to four
oh let's one in the air left center
horizon on the move he won't get there
calhoun into second
and the hit parade continues that's four
consecutive hits for the diamondbacks to
start the seventh inning
marshall is now hit safely in 11 of his
last 13 games
marshall belts it to center her radio
broke in
and he won't get there it's over his
head calhoun coming around third varsity
second diamondbacks have the lead
ramos hits a fly ball deep to right it
backs up solaire he's got it here comes
marshall and it's six to four
[Applause]
and matsuk did just that and that
retires the side but boy that inning
hurt five runs five consecutive hits
arizona enjoys now a 6-4 lead in the
hands of jb wendelkin who will close in
the ninth and he's got one save on the
resume looking for number two right here
3-2
center field varshall
diamondbacks on the day they announce a
contract extension for their manager
tori lavello
get a win they come back to take it six
to four